the streets of tachov are silent
there are no children at the elementary
school local shops are closed
with new coronavirus variants raging
across the czech republic
this is one of the country's worst
affected regions
deputy mayor joseph horacek tries to
keep track of the numbers
he says everyone here knows someone who
died of covet 19.
i realized many of those who died were
people my age
or even younger
i realized i would never see them again
to go fishing watch soccer
or have a beer that really gets to you
in the local health center the first
responders tell us
they feel totally overwhelmed and
frustrated
there is no hospital in town that means
patients with severe
cases of covid19 have to be transferred
to a clinic
50 kilometers away magdalena says
sometimes she doesn't have the energy to
wake up and go to work
the emergency doctor recently lost her
father to the pandemic
because i'm a doctor i was allowed to
say goodbye to my dad
and to stay with him until the very last
moment
i don't want anyone to have to see
what's going on in covet wards
where patients suffocate even if they're
given oxygen
they're in pain you cannot imagine that
exhausted front workers residents in
resignation
and all this while the pandemic rages on
across the region
tahoe is less than 20 minutes drive from
neighboring germany but the border has
been closed
this has disrupted the lives of many
cross-border commuters
some have even lost their jobs
i need a job i am
it is taking too long people want jobs
they have to pay their bills
unfortunately this is the reality
tahoe's deputy mayor is pinning his
hopes on vaccines
even though so far vaccinations are only
taking place here
once a week meanwhile dr magdalena
yanchova pulls herself together
every single day so she can keep doing
her job
hoping that one day soon the pandemic
will be over
well for more i'm joined by yuri hoshek
tv commentator of td cesnam
in the capital prague yuri how did it
get so bad the country had some of the
lowest infection rates in europe
and now one of the highest in the world
good morning to you well i think we put
uh the foot of the pedal especially in
summer 2020
and when we were one of the best
countries in europe concerning handling
the pandemic
and basically the government was sending
wrong signals to the public
in a sense that the worst is probably uh
behind us
and also in autumn 2020 and around
christmas was way too hesitant
inconclusive probably hand handling
the crisis on so-called popular demand
uh having parliamentary elections on the
horizon
in october 2021
and also there is a lack of
communication
we have now in march 2021 we're still
waiting uh
for an official uh nationwide campaign
concerning vaccination
uh which is just just shambolic and uh
to be honest i think the part of the
guild is also on
on the side of ordinary people so to say
in a way that they're not
obeying the rules the way they they
should
and also i would say the the police
should be a lot stricter
uh towards those who are just not
probably wearing masks in the public so
it's a combination of factors
yeah you allude to poor communication
being one of them from the czech
government
being a big factor have they since
communicated
why it took so long to act as the
situation got worse
i think there is some really crisis
inside the government uh about the whole
system how to handle crisis because
prime minister andre babish repeatedly
said
that the he is actually the key person
concerning uh
the rollout of vaccine the whole
communication of the crisis the
the micromanagement we've had already
uh three ministers of health uh in the
span of one month
just failing to handle uh the whole
problem
uh we have coalition government the the
communication between ministries has
been
quite poor so again it's it's a
combination a mixture of factors
and very briefly yuri what's been done
to improve the situation going forward
well right now we have a lockdown which
is the most strict from what we've
experienced since
since last year we that pretty much the
next step would only be to switch
off the industry and limit the movement
of people
uh in a space of couple of hundred
meters from their homes
so i think now the figures we will see
next next week in two weeks
will actually improve and also as the
vaccination rollout
has improved so this is actually the the
path the way out of the darkness
giddy horshack in prague many thanks
pleasure